tell your story in the cut because you
know that is
where the story actually lives
it lives in between the juxtaposition of
two scenes
it it it lives in the transition
of those two scenes
so it's within the cut yeah yeah yeah
that's
the other thing i i like to talk about
is telling the story in the cut
telling the story in the cut is is
simple um it's it's a little simpler
than
than i think a lot of people make it and
i um people tell writers and they tell
filmmakers and they tell directors
you know um you know show not
tell show not tell show not tell she
will not tell
and that can be kind of really confusing
because it's like you listen to those
words
and you're like okay what the hell does
that mean you know
what does that mean really show not
tell okay um how do you
show a screenplay i don't understand
what that means you know it's like
it's like and so like when you're you're
a writer and you're like
you're hitting yourself with those words
like i don't get it uh
uh i'm telling intrinsically by writing
it
uh you know so it can be really
confusing
but see what it actually means
is tell your story in the cut
because you know that is where the story
actually lives it lives in between the
juxtaposition
of two scenes it it it lives
in the transition of those two scenes
so the period between those two scenes
is where all the information
of your story is uploaded so all the
exposition
that you need to make in your story can
be implied
it could be all implied you don't
actually have to say the exposition
like like i would say like what
seventy percent of your your exposition
does not have to go into your script
it can be all in in your cut
because all you have to do is like
is is set up a um
a visual cue with an action
and then cut to the end result of that
action
to the aftermath and just by doing that
just by putting one picture here all
right
and then putting the end result of that
picture right over here
you've downloaded your or you've
uploaded your exposition
done you know so like
the example i use is like is is the
um is the girl like you know at the
at the bar um at the at the hotel bar
and the bartender comes up to her and
gives her a drink and then signals
towards a man
at the end of the bar who waves at her
because he sends her to drink
and then cut to later they're in the
in the in a hotel hallway stumbling into
her hotel suite
kissing and we know what happens you
know we don't need to know
what they discussed at the bar we don't
need to know what their conversation was
we don't need to know all the details in
between
we we get it we get it
and it's it's a really really simple
technique and not
and and there are a lot of
filmmakers um and writers
that don't avail themselves of it and
there are a lot of writers that do
um number one on the list is
kenneth lonergan who is a brilliant
writer
and um he knows exactly how to do that
um and um
yeah william goldman also knew exactly
how to do that so but but yeah it's um
yeah it's it's a simple thing you know
more people need to do it that's all
how did you get better at telling your
stories within the cut
sometimes it was hard won um
because um
i had this tendency i think like a lot
of new writers do
to um want to fall in love with their
language
and to hold like some kind of like
chunky like
diner scene with like you know some
interesting characters
talking and like throwing some colorful
banter back and forth and like oh how
interesting this
is and when when
when i started to realize that it was
unnecessary
and that not only was it unnecessary
that it was
it was um it was shooting on me myself
in the foot as far as it as far as
i'm grabbing the intent the attention of
readers
um it's not to say that those characters
may not have been doing or saying
anything
that was um interesting or fun or
it was dropping the ball you know in the
ball game
as far as like making making my work
stand out for others
because essentially what i learned is
that
in the the in the long and short of it
um
readers aren't interested in um
your scene they
don't care about your scene they care
about the story you're telling them
that's what they care about
they don't care about your scene they
care about the story you're telling them
so if they fall in love with your story
they'll they'll they'll fall in love
with your script
they're not going to fall in love with
your scene you know
they're not in it to fall in love with
so yeah although there is something very
charming about
those diner conversations i can't i know
i i
enjoy seeing them you know and then
you've got marge the waitress all right
what'll it be
and then you know then they she leaves
and then they're trying to like talk
you know so that she doesn't well that's
a whole other
i mean that's a whole other discussion
it depends on where it is
and it depends on how you do that sort
of thing
um um is is one thing
and you know like for example my
my favorite my one of my favorite diner
conversations
of course is because it's charged
you charge a scene you charge a scene by
telling it
um by telling your story in the in in
cuts
all right by by loading
um your story like that um
heat yes excellent you you
you charge everything is very
very um sparse and very
um um
there's not much going on in heat other
than
the the action um the reactions
um the the setups for the heist
it's it's very lean
heat and then it gets to that diner
scene
between patino and um and de niro
and it means everything
that conversation a conversation means
everything
and that's how you load those scenes
by by you know telling your story
and then you come to a scene where
there is you know more or less
you know a standoff if it's not a
metaphorical standoff
it's not emotional standoff
that's how you tell stories in general
you know
you can't have that standoff
in every scene of your script
otherwise you're confused about what
you're doing
sure and then keeping it lighter
the 80s 90s sing-along scene which i
don't know why they
used for so long where something's on
the radio
somebody turns on a stereo and now the
whole group's singing together
that seems to be lost and i'm happy that
that's the case
you know i don't i don't mind stuff like
that i don't i don't mind
anything that's experimental like that
as long as everything else is tight
you know um you can do anything
experimental
but if everything else is tight
it it it'll it will um
it will like rise to the top okay um
i i i'm a i'm a personally you know
i mean it's it's not my favorite film
okay but
i am a sucker for that
hollow note scene in 500 days
okay all right i am a sucker for that
scene
because i've been that guy okay
[Laughter]
i've walked out of that
it's swinging like that okay so i've
been that guy so i'm a sucker
you know so i mean like so if you do it
right you know
it it flies it flies
you